welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and obi-wan kenobi on disney plus
just confirmed a major figure from star
wars lore is coming jedi master quinlan
voss and as i told uncle dryden boss all
star wars bosses are bound to celebrate
each other so welcome back uncle quinlan
as in order 66 survivors smuggling force
sensitive young lanes to safety several
clues from quinlan's mysterious yearbook
quote to cast tweets to why this series
opened with order 66 other than to
trigger us are now pointing in an
interesting direction that we may now
finally get an answer to who saved grogu
from the jedi temple and was it someone
from the boss family a reminder that
quinlan vos was a jedi master who first
came up during the prequel era and
phantom menace in moscow on tatooine
there was an unnamed background
character with yellow face paint whom
fans became obsessed with so lucasfilm's
story team gave him a fuller background
and named quinlan boss in the republic
comics from darkhorse storylines are now
considered non-canon but george lucas
liked quinlan voss so much that he
planned to include him in revenge of the
sith in the battle of kashyyyk he was
going to be riding a republic tank and
get an awesome move but this scene was
never shot and lucas's script reduced
quinlan down to just one line and master
vos has moved his troops to boss pity by
the way boss pity is a mid-rim planet
that also came up in rebels but was
originally created for star wars
obsession comics also by dark horse also
non-canon now but in those stories it
was a separatist staging ground for
their republic raids anyway years later
quinlan vos appeared in a season 3
episode of clone wars hunt for zero when
obi-wan and quinlan team up to find the
escaped zero the hutt to the hut home
world of nalhata after that boss's role
was meant to be expanded to a longer arc
but clone wars was cancelled or rather
put on hiatus in 2013 but quinlan boss's
storyline became the basis of the 2015
novel dark disciple by christy golden in
which vos joins count dooku's once
apprentice asajj ventress a major
recurring character in clone wars in a
doomed romance that features boss giving
into the dark side but ultimately
renouncing it after asajj's death we
don't know yet how much of dark disciple
is going to be confirmed as official
star wars canon especially since all the
names on the walls of that mapuzo
safehouse were all the names of jedi
from legends material constantly these
live-action titles are canonizing
details from legends which i think
ultimately is a good thing but quinlan
boss was always confirmed to have
survived order 66 the 2017 darth vader
comics by charles soule listed his name
alongside other jedi survivors whom the
inquisitors were currently hunting and
in that same run on moncala runaway jedi
farron barr mentions quinlan boss as the
name of someone who could possibly help
them ferenvar was a jedi padawan who was
able to escape order 66 trying to
resettle all those jedi in hiding a
similar mission that quinlan is now on
as this latest episode of obi-wan kenobi
confirms quinlan voss is an active
resource to jedi refugees after order
66. obi-wan finds his name on the wall
of the mapuzo safe house quinlan was
here yeah he helps now and again
smuggling younglings there it is
smuggling younglings that right there is
a key contextual clue that quinlan voss
had both the motive and the opportunity
to be the mystery jedi who rescued the
young lane grogu from the jedi temple
remember we first learned grogu's name
in mandalorian season 2 when ahsoka said
this many masters trained him over the
years at the end of the clone wars when
the empire rose to power he was hidden
someone took him from the temple now
remember ahsoka did not know of grogu's
existence before this moment meaning the
child was a secret confined only to a
group of jedi masters a series of
masters whom sokha said trained him over
the years and we know quinlan vos has
the rank of master because obi-wan and
revenge of the sith called him master
boss the book of obafete flashed back to
the knight of order 66 from grogoo's
perspective from inside his bassinet
groho witnesses three jedi dying
fighting the 500 first jedi who are
never named this moment is going down in
the jedi temple dormitories you can tell
by the diamond-shaped markings on the
doors that match those of the temple
dorms in the season five episode of
clone wars when anakin visited paris
offi now we do not see that particular
area in the obi-wan kenobi prologue
scene that all unfolds in a classroom
terrace and then moves on to the main
hall of all the jedi you see on the
floor getting gunned down you don't
really see any familiar faces but as
jedi after jedi falls when we cut to
black only two are left standing both of
whom have green lightsabers and the one
on the right even uses a pretty awesome
force push quinlan boss's lightsaber we
should note was green now we gotta talk
about how our friends at epic hero shop
have released some awesome new designs
this month show your love for the
obi-wan kenobi series by embracing the
light side with the high ground a design
that features our hero in a stained
glass window fit for a jedi temple or
you can get kenobi's lightsaber
schematics on a t-shirt if you prefer an
elegant weapon for a more civilized age
they've also dropped a pride collection
so you can celebrate pride and your
fandom all month long wear one to your
next pride parade or party and if you've
been binging stranger things like the
rest of the world then you will love
tales from the multiverse number three
uncanny things eleven isn't the only one
with superpowers and this x-men stranger
things crossover and the best part is
they're having a flash sale this week on
their summer collection so go to
epicheroshop.com for 10 off all these
designs with the promo code sum 10 sum
10. i just really enjoy all the nerdy
designs that they're rolling out this
summer over at epic hero and i know you
will too these quality shirts will have
you feeling cool and comfortable all
summer long shop all these designs and
even more over at
epicheroshop.com and now as we're
halfway through this season we've met
pretty much everyone in the main cast
with two exceptions o'shea jackson jr
and maya erskine no details have been
announced yet for either of their
characters but as of this taping as
we've only seen the first three episodes
i can recall when i attended star wars
celebration last week and made my way to
the seat for the screenings of the first
two episodes of obi-wan kenobi i was
able to pass the vip area where i
definitely saw o'shea jackson jr seated
and while i would have loved for the guy
to point at me and say boss leaving me
to wonder how many s's he pronounced the
guy was at least there leading me to
believe he's playing some significant
character and jackson is credited for
episodes four five and six so it stands
to reason he's gonna be playing someone
important who joins obi-wan as obi-wan
navigates this path for jedi refugees
throughout the rest of the season and in
recent days as the obi-wan kenobi cast
and crew have had to come to the defense
of co-star moses ingram against some
garbage some trolls have been sending
her oh shea jackson jr tweeted a joke
about james earl jones voicing darth
vader and then quote they are gonna love
finding out what my character does if
o'shea jackson jr is playing quinlan
boss and as of now that's still an if
what sacred chapter of star wars history
could his character been instrumental to
that jackson would be referring to here
if not to be the jedi master who
smuggled our beloved grogu from the jedi
temple now i have speculated many jedi
survivors who could have rescued grogu
including the theory that mace windu
might have survived and crawled his way
to the temple to get grogo out of there
i still hope that windu survived but
based on this latest episode of obi-wan
kenobi and everything we know about
queen lin boss as people on sports
twitter say underneath out of context
thumbnails with big yellow text and
someone asks who is this from voss now
looks like the likeliest suspect quinlan
voss is an expert tracker with insights
into the criminal underworld that the
lofty jedi often steered clear of he's
known for having a lover named colleen
hinz after order 66 that could actually
be erskine's character boss is known for
having psychometry a retrocognition the
ability to sense someone's memories just
by touching objects they've come into
contact with which could be how he was
able to connect with the unspeaking
grogu and learned his story and boss
would be eager to stay in contact with
jedi since his former apprentice ayla
sakura died on fellowship or as
jackson's father would say bye fellucia
i'm sorry i had to in this episode
obi-wan gonna be tala explains how the
empire is still kidnapping for sensitive
kids and that sounds like the same kind
of imperial plot that led to dr pershing
and moff gideon wanting grogu in the
mandalorian and i'll leave you with
quinlan's quote he says only when the
eyes are closed
can you truly see
see what
[Music]
the way
way capitalized grogu spent years hiding
in that bassinet its hood closed closed
off from the ward in darkness as ahsoka
said everything after guru who left the
temple was in darkness that darkness
could be the way that quinlan now
describes a way that ironically will
lead grogu to joining the mandalorian
din jarrin who preaches this is the way
let me know your thoughts on this theory
and go easy on me if you're watching
this weeks after i posted it and i'm
completely wrong you gotta admit halfway
through the season seemed like a pretty
good theory right follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos follow me rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you